What's up,
man? We did
that. data.
Machine learning and
AI basically, you
know, they sell
to they sell
to like
[Music]
Well, I never
knew
what I
saw. You're
not following Jim Kramer. You're
following Nancy Pelosi. No, that's
that's how I chose my company.
Professor, did Nancy Pelosi invest in
the company? No one knew about this
company until she balls. Okay. Couple
thousand dollars of calls came in on it.
There you go. Okay, folks. Welcome. And
um I sent that email yesterday about
dates because everything's coming
stacked on top of everything else and I
just wanted to make sure there was no
confusion about the dates. So next quiz
is on next Monday, right? 3:30 to 4, I'm
sorry, 1:30 to 2. Um the numbers from
your valuation are due on Sunday night
before the last class. Just the numbers.
what you got as your intrinsic value,
what you got as your pricing, what your
recommendation is because I need it for
that last class. Monday, of course, your
project is due by the end of the
day. And then I have two I have two
choices for your final exam. One is you
can take it online early on May
8th and the second is you can take it
either in person or online on May
12th with no or I'm sorry May 14th the
the regular day the regular final which
is the very end of the final exams week
but it gives you more time to prepare
but this way I want I was trying to
remove any conceivable excuses you could
have for not doing well in the final
which is you made me do it online. I
could do it in person. You can take it
in person if you want, but it'll have to
be made. You think what if I want to do
it in person on May? Well, I'm out of
options. I can't create more choices
here because it just gets messier and
messier. So, you can take it either
online or in person early or later.
Yeah. Great.
I haven't made my final judgment on the
final exam. it might eventually be
exactly the same kind of exam, you know,
so I'll let you know ahead of time. So
if that's your choice, online versus,
you know, partial credit versus multiple
choice, that might not even be an issue.
The exams will all be open-ended.
Basically, they will be the same kind of
past exams. But the May 8th exam and the
May 12th, May 14th exam will be
different exams for obvious reasons,
right? Because the May 8th exam will
already be out in the public domain.
Once something goes out there in the
world we live in, I assume it's public
knowledge already. Honor code not
dishonor code notwithstanding. So
basically the exams will be different.
Will they be equally difficult? I have
no idea. I haven't even written the
exams. I don't know whether they'll be
equally easy, equally difficult, you
know, just as messed up. But yet another
question about the final
exam any credit for that's why I said
it's I haven't made the decision the
multiple choice obviously there is no
partial credit the one thing I have to
make sure is logistically how easy is it
to grade online when you have regular
questions so I'm testing that out if it
looks like I can grade the exams online
quickly you know so that I'm not going
then I might just give the same type of
exam. So that choice might not even be
the issue between online and in person.
It might all be same type of exam you've
seen in previous final exams. Okay. So
today, excuse me, today we're going to
talk about private company valuations.
As a leadin, let's do a start of the
class test. Let's assume that Jessica
owns a
company and Wit owns is is an investor
in a publicly traded company.
The companies look exactly the same in
terms of operations, cash flows,
growth, but you're trying to estimate
the cost of equity for these companies.
So the only diff, excuse me, the only
difference is Jessica owns a business, a
privately owned business with his
investor in a publicly traded company.
I'm interested only in the cost of
equity. So far, we haven't drawn a
distinction, right? In a public company,
we usually are price takers. Even though
you might not be diversified, you got to
estimate a cost of equity through the
eyes of the marginal investor. The
company was diversified. So we use bas
and cost of equity. So then this was
never an issue. But if you were
estimating the cost of equity for a
private business, privately owned
business and a public company in the
same space looks exactly the same. My
question is purely one about the cost of
equity. Is the cost of equity going to
be higher for the publicly traded
company? The privately owned business
should be sent mid private company will
have higher cost effective. Okay, tell
me why. It's the same company, same
operation. So why is it that's making
Jessica see more risk than W is because
the marginal investor is not who's the
marginal investor in Jessica's business?
She and what's the question you need to
ask her before you decide what cost of
equity? Does she have a good investment?
What other investments you made? Right.
If Jessica has all of her wealth tied up
in this one business, when she looks at
the business, what risk does she see?
All risk, right? This is a question of
what's what's diversifiable,
non-diversifiable, becomes an
abstraction. So when she estimates cost
of equity, she's looking at total risk
because she is completely
undiversified. But that's why I said you
need to ask the question because if she
is a really she's a bill, let's say
Jessica is really a billionaire. She is
actually she's been hiding this but
she's been really a billionaire and this
is a $100 million
business. She might actually be in the
same position of because to her this so
it's really not a question of private
versus public. It's who the investor in
the businesses and whether they're
diversified. So today we're going to
talk about how to adjust the cost of
equity in private business. In public
companies you can't play this game
because there is always that choice you
have of investing in index fund. If you
choose to put all your money in Nvidia
and you lost 5% of your money today, I
have zero sympathy for you, right? You
are greedy. You went for it. But just
like the person who puts everything on
number 23 in a casino table, if you
lose, you lose. But in a private
business, Jessica is fully invested in
this business because she had no choice.
She had to take every dollar she owned
and put in the business because it's not
like your billions coming out from
somewhere else. So we're going to talk
about adjusting cost of equity when
people are not diversified in the
private business space. Now the other
thing we've not talked about with public
companies and we value them is we never
talked about liquidity,
right? We value the company. We came up
with the DCF value. So you could have a
stock company like Michael's company
which is you know lightly known, not
heavily traded and you could have an
Apple and we treat them the same way.
So are we being completely oblivious to
liquidity or how in a public market does
liquidity play out investment decision
spread in the bid spread right so if
Michael finds his stock to be
undervalued he goes to his brokerage
account I'm not going to make it
personal ask him which brokerage account
he uses but there's a brokerage account
and he tries to buy the stock the price
at which he buys is going to be
different than the price that the bid
aspirate and if you have an illquid
stock, the spread's going to be wider.
What does that mean? A company can look
undervalued because you're comparing it
to a market price. The market price is
often the midpoint of the
spread by the time you actually try to
transact. You might say, "I can't buy
the stock. It looks cheap to me, but the
bid ask spread is too wide." So, in
public companies, the bid ass spread
takes care of the problem because when
we go to buy or sell a stock, the prices
will reflect the liquidity of the stock.
But in a private business there is this
issue of if I buy a private business
there isn't a liquidity issue. It's not
explicit. So what do I have to do? I
have to bring in that cost
into my
valuation. And I call this the price of
buyer
remorse. Have you ever had buyer's
remorse with a publicly traded stock?
Well, here's how it'll play out.
You see Jim Kramer at 3:35 p.m. on CNBC
and he tells you to buy something and in
a moment of weakness you actually buy
it and 2 minutes later you whack your
head. So what was I thinking? This guy
yells out a name of a random company.
Every 2 minutes I bought a company and
you decide to sell it 2 minutes later
assuming the price hasn't changed. You
still have a cost. The cost is the bid
aspirate. You say how big can it be for
a stock like Apple? It can be.1%.
But first, but let's say you, you know,
at the end of class today, you're tired.
You stop at the local hot dog stand guy
outside. You buy the stand. I don't know
how this works out. You say, "Look, I've
always liked your stand. You take your
entire family savings." So, Michael on
his way out stops and buys the hot dog
stand. Your savings have now been
removed from stocks. You're worried
about the stock market. You now own a
hot dog stand. Michael gets home and
tells his wife about what he's just
done. What do you think your wife's
reaction is going to be, Michael?
What were you thinking? Go back and sell
the stand right away. So, Michael makes
his way all the way back here and he
stands on the sidewalk and as you guys
walk back, do you want to buy the hot
dogs? Not buy a hot dog, but buy the
stand. Much more difficult to get it off
your hands, right? So, what do you have
to do? You've got to be preemptive. You
got to reduce how much you pay up front
just to cover the cost of buyers some
more. So understand the logic for why in
private company valuation you apply this
discount on your value for a
liquidity. But having accepted that let
me ask you a question about whether that
discount should vary across businesses.
And I'm going to give you four different
businesses and I want to tell you which
ones you should see the biggest in
liquidity discount and which ones the
smallest in liquidity discount. The
first is a money-making cash flow
generating
business where you are a long-term
buyer. You're not going to see your
spouse for 5 years. So, you know, I have
five years of escape hats before I
actually have to be held accountable.
The second is a profitable cash flow
generating company to a cash constrained
buyer where you might need the cash
flows for something a health care scare,
a tuition payment, a house
payment, an unprofitable negative cash
flow business. And again, so basically a
choice between profitable cash flow
business, unprofitable negative cash
flow business, long-term buyer versus
cash constraint buyer. Let's separate
the two.
Right? Profitable cash flow generating
business versus money losing negative
cash flow business. Which one should
have the higher discount? Money losing.
And why why is that? Why do I accept a
smaller liquidity discount with a
money-making cash flow generating
business? Cash because the cash comes at
in a sense I get the liquidity from my
cash flows. Already you can see that the
discount I should be applying should
vary across companies.
It should also vary across buyers,
right? If you're a person who doesn't
need cash, you don't care as much about
liquidity as somebody who might need the
cash. So, it should vary across
buyers. It's getting more nuanced
already. Should it vary across
time? Would you be attaching a bigger
discount today than maybe 6 months
ago? The world's become a lot scarier,
right? There's an illquidity issue that
basically in periods where you feel
scared when equity risk premiums rise
you're going to demand more for
liquidity the discount should vary
across companies should vary across
buyers should vary across time and this
is my core problem with how private
company appraisals deal with the
liquidity you know what they do they use
what I call the bludgeon approach every
business they value they knock off 20%.
money making, money losing, long-term
buyer, cash constraint buyer, good
times, bad
times. We could talk about how to
estimate the liquidity discard. It's one
of the most difficult debates and
valuations coming up, but it's got to be
dynamic. It's got to vary across
companies. It's got to vary across
buyers. Now, one final question before
we actually look at the mechanics. Let's
say you own a private business.
We talked about liquidity. We've talked
about
diversification. You want to sell your
private business and you want to find
the best potential buyer for this
business. Best in the sense you get the
highest number, right? And I'll give you
the choices. You can look for another
private individual who will buy your
business. Let's call that a private
owner. You can maybe get a PE fund
invested in your
company. You can look at a publicly
traded company. Let's stay with those
three. Which of those three is going to
be in the best position to offer you the
highest price? Michael, the strategic
public and strategic will make it even
better because that will mean they'll
overpay. But let's take the strategic
out. What is it about the public buyer
that'll give you the higher value? Give
you the higher value because they can
offer you shares for the company or
their investors are diversified. So they
don't have this issue of not being
diver. The company doesn't have to be
diversified. the investors in the
company and as a public company. And why
do you not care about liquidity if
you're a public
company? Cuz you buy the asset. If your
investors want liquidity, what do they
do? They don't have to sell the asset,
just sell their shares,
right? Both those issues
disappear. We'll talk more about why
then every private company doesn't get
sold to a public company. Some of them
do and it in fact explains why some
businesses over time start off as
businesses which are basically
controlled by lots of private businesses
but eventually become public companies
garbage disposal in the US one point in
time every city used to have its own
garbage usually controlled by the mafia
but that's a different story right but
every bit every company is a private
today if you look across companies like
Browning Ferris were created by rolling
up
It's a process of buying private
businesses. Blockbuster
video rentals when they started and most
of you don't remember when I remember
when video rental companies first showed
up. You know these mom and pop
operations they buy videos random videos
sometimes and then Blockbuster Video
went around town by town picking and
choosing which video rental stores to
buy and they create a company. And
already you can see the pieces that make
a roll up play out because you're
effectively taking small private
businesses where liquidity is an issue
rolling them up into a public company
and magically create value by just the
process of rolling up. So let's go back
to where I left you on the slides where
I gave you this question of with private
company valuations why does motive
matter and talk a little bit about how
that plays out in practice.
So what I'd like to do is actually look
at four sets of transactions. Starting
with the most difficult private to
private
transactions where one private
individual owning a business sells to
another private individual. Then private
to public and I'm going to give you the
the exact the limiting case that private
to private private to public because all
the problems go
away. Private to IPO where you're not
you're going public yourself, right?
rather than selling to a public
company. Not every private business
obviously has this choice, but if you're
large enough, you've scaled up enough,
you're attractive enough, you might go
public on your own. And then private to
VC to public, you're creating a
transition point where VCs come in, they
provide the capital, and then you go
public. So let's start with private to
private transactions and look at why
private to private transactions are in a
sense the most nightmarish scenario in
valuation because all of these pieces
that you don't usually deal with come
into play. First usually neither the
buyer nor the seller is
diversified. You know medical practices
and dental practices almost every
transaction used to be private to
private. In the old days, a doctor would
get to 7075 and what they would do is
they sell their practice to a 35 or a
40-y old doctor who wanted to buy a
practice. We'll talk about what's
changed in that business, but
essentially private to private. Neither
could be diversified because you're a
doctor. Every dollar you had went into
that practice because you maintain it.
And especially the young buyer buying
the young doctor buying the practice not
only had no assets, they had a lot of
loans to pay off because they'd been in
medical school for 10 years before they
became doctors and that loan hangs out
over there. So neither the buyer nor the
seller is diversified. Second, the
investment is by definition
illquid. It's not that you can't sell
it. It just means if you sell it, you
got to take a big hit if you want to
sell it quickly. And
third, there's a key person issue and
medical practice is a perfect
example. I mean, most of us, I would say
every everyone in this room as a doctor,
right?
And usually the doctor has a name and
you have that you know it used to be
less it's less so than it used to be but
you pick a person as your doctor because
you trust them or you don't trust them
or they're the only one allowed by your
insurance might be the reason you're
losing but you're you're you're picking
a person as a doctor. They're not
interchangeable for the most part. It's
not like you walk in a random other
person says I'm a doctor too. It's okay
that's fine. We're all doctors, you
know, it's everything's going to be the
same. There's a key person issue, which
is when you sell your
practice, that practice is built on who
you are as a person. And if you buy that
practice as a young doctor, the existing
patients might not stay with you because
they don't know you, they don't like
you, they don't know, they don't feel
connected to. That's something again you
have to build into the
valuation. And I'm going to argue that
this isn't just private business. It's
build over into public companies. Now
this key person
issue and how to bring it into
valuation. So I'm going to take a very
simple example to illustrate this
process. So let's say you're looking at
a restaurant. It's an upscale
restaurant. It's a French restaurant.
The chef owns a restaurant. Highly
regarded. It's been doing well. You have
the financials for the company. You're
an investment banker. You're buying the
restaurant. Why? Because you're tired of
investment banking.
You always wanted to you don't want to
cook but you like the idea of you've
been watching a lot of restaurant shows
on TV and you watch Gordon Ramsay and he
looks like an investment bank in terms
of how he yells at people. So I can do
that too. So you are an investment
banker. You're going to cash out and
this is going to be critical to your
story. You're going to cash out all your
savings and put your entire wealth into
this restaurant.
You have access to the financial
statements. Most recent year, the
company reported 1.2 million in
revenues, $400,000 in operating pre-tax
operating profit. It has no conventional
debt. It is $120,000 in lease
commitments, present value of lease
commitments over time. Right? So, I'm
sorry, $120,000 in lease commitments
every year for the next 12 years. So,
I'm going to show you what the numbers
look like from the financials. Then
let's say that this is not a restaurant
with two sets of books. You know what I
mean, right? One for the tax guy, one
for you. These are there's only one
book. They're official books that record
with the company. And as you can see
that the company has reported operating
income of 400,000 in the most recent
deal. But I there's one thing I do have
to add in here that might come into
consideration in terms of how much US
investment bankers should pay for the
restaurant. That chef, that well-
reggarded chef that filled up this
restaurant doesn't pay
himself a salary. Why? Why should he
bother? Right? It's his restaurant. He
gets whatever's left over. Now, do you
see why this has to be something you got
to factor in? Who's going to own the
restaurant after you buy it? You do,
right? Who's in the kitchen the day
after you buy it? How are you going to
cook? What exactly you going to cook?
structured
products, mortgage back securities. You
don't know how to cook. You've seen
cooking on
TV. You got to hire somebody to do what
that chef did. It can't be just some guy
off the street say, "Come cook some
French food for
me." So, you got think about what is
that going to cost me and bring it in.
It's just common sense, right? You got
to bring it in otherwise you're going to
overpay for the restaurant.
So let's go through this process.
Starting with the messiest part of the
process. You need a discount rate. Cost
of equity and a cost of capital. And
while the basic principles still apply,
riskier businesses have higher discount
rates. The fundamental problem here is
you as the buyer. It's not about the
sellith. You as the buyer are not
diversified. Therefore, when you look at
risk, you can't look at risk through the
eyes of a marginal investor who's
diversified. you are the marginal
investor, you're not
diversified. We have to change the way
we think about risk. And it's not
difficult because the starting point is
going to look exactly like it did for
publicly traded companies. How do we get
basically traded companies? We went and
look for other companies in the business
and we did a bottom up beta. I'm going
to give you two alternative peer groups
and I'll let you pick which one you
think should be the peer group for this
particular upscale French restaurant.
The first is a group of restaurant
companies. We'll go to Capital IQ. Ask
for restaurant companies. You get a
list, right? Who are you going to find
in the list? McDonald's, TGI Fridays,
Chipotle, Shake Shack.
First, if you show this to a French chef
and say, "These are your pure
group," the guy won't even look at the
rest of your numbers. He is out of
there, right? I mean, it'll freak them
out. These are fast food places. And
this, the second choice I made was I
asked, "Who eats at, you know, expensive
French
restaurants? Even without wine, it'll
cost you what? $200 entree, appetizer,
napkin.
In Italy actually there is this napkin
charge I didn't even know about the
first time I went to Italy the waiters
chased me
down napkins. Why do you charge me for
the napkins? Cuz you took the table I
guess. So $200. Who spends $200 on
dinner? It's going to pass through your
system pretty quickly. So you know who
spends $200 on dinner, right? People
spending other people's money.
and I let you list out the groups. So
basically, I could look at investment
banking firms as my peer group saying
they're the if they do well, I do well
or people who feel rich that day. They
got a bonus. So it's really it's it's
the same kind of people who shop at
luxury goods stores. So my second peer
group is high-end special retailers. I
walk down Fifth Avenue saying, "Okay,
okay, okay." Listing of that stretch of
Fifth Avenue, no Gucci, Farerraamo,
etc., etc. Farraama is not publicly
traded, but you go down the
list. So, two different groups. So, you
can you get an unleavened beta that's
very different. 086 used restaurants,
1.18. I'll show you what I picked, but
I'll let you think about. And now, I
want you to open up that question about
pure group. It doesn't have to be the
same SIC code. You're not locked into
that. You're asking about companies that
do well when you do well and badly when
you do badly.
So now I'm going to lay out what's
different. If this were a publicly
traded restaurant, I would use the 1.18
beta, the highend pure group retail
beta, and move on. Right? My argument
would be investors are diversified, the
rest of the risk goes away. But that's
not the case here.
So if you what I've done here is
essentially taken the total risk of a
company broke it down into
non-diversifiable risk and diversifiable
risk. In a public company we ignore the
diversifiable
risk. So we just look at the
non-diversifiable risk. We capture the
beta from it. We take the beta of the
regressions and we use a bottom up beta.
But if you think in purely algebra
terms, if you're exposed to the rest of
the risk, your cost of equity has to be
high enough to cover the rest of the
risk. Wouldn't it be nice if we could
somehow figure out how much of the risk
in a restaurant company
comes from the market and how much of it
is
diversifiable? Yeah, it would be. And in
fact, it's there, right? If you look at
the Bloomberg Beta page, you notice
there's an R squar and an R inlet
regression. What do they measure
statistically? The measure the
proportion of your dependent variable
that is explained by the independent
variable. The dependent variable here is
the market. The independent variable is
the company. So the R squ tells you the
proportion of variance in your stock
that is explained by the
market. Hey, that's exactly what market
risk is. So you know in addition to
getting the betas from publicly traded
companies, I get the R squares from the
publicly traded companies. And I set it
up as an algebra problem. 40% of my risk
is market risk and I'm demanding a beta
of
0.88 but I'm now not diversifying expose
the remaining 60%. If this were an
algebra problem in sixth grade, you can
tell me what the beta would look like,
right? It's got to be scaled up for the
extra 60%, my8 beta will become
two, reflecting the fact that I'm not
diversified. I concocted this measure in
the '90s after I did a session for
private company
appraisers and we're talking about the
cost of equity and I said, you know,
traditional cost of because all their
numbers come from public markets. They
have no choice. They do the risk-free
rate plus beta times risk premium. I
said, "How do you deal with the fact
that in private businesses people who
are buying the business are not
diversified?" And they said, "We just
add an extra
10%." And they said, "Why?" He said,
"Because they're not diversified." So
why? I said that's not the why I'm
asking. I said, "Why 10%." So that's
what we all do. That doesn't work for
me. First, it makes it a fixed number,
right? Every business I'm adding 10%. So
I concocted this measure because it
comes from the same public company
data and that total beta captures the
risk to a completely undiversified
investor other.
Yeah. Yeah. Same thing I do exactly what
and you know just like in betas you
might you know you worry about outliers
you don't have to worry as much with R
squares obviously because the highest R
squared can be only one and so you don't
have the range but it's if you're using
median for the beta use the median R squ
as well so my total beta measure is not
rocket science it's just built on the
same standards that I used to measure
risk but I'm now looking at total risk
so I'm basing your risk on your standard
deviation rather than the portion of
your standard deviation that you can't
diversify. Beta in fact is a standard
deviation measure of risk. For those of
you remember the original equation for
beta that comes out of a regression,
it's row j the correlation between the
stock and the market times the standard
deviation of the stock in the numerator
and the standard deviation of the market
in the denominator. That's how we get
bets. Okay? So all I'm doing is I'm
taking the R squ and the square root of
the R squ obviously is the correlation
the R dividing the beta that I get for
the sector by the correlation of that
sector with the
market. So in this case the 1.18 total
beta that I got by looking at those
high-end retailers. I also looked at the
R squares of all of the companies in
that sector. The correlation was 0.5.
Effectively, I'm doubling the beta to
reflect the fact that the buyer, in this
case, you are not diversified. I'm not
going to do this automatically. I'm
going to ask who's the buyer because
that's going to drive whether I do this
in the first place. That's going to push
up my beta. The rest becomes more
simple. You know, basically, I start
with that unleavened beta. If it's a
publicly traded company, what do I need?
I need a market debt to equity ratio for
the company. And here I run into a
second problem with private businesses.
Why? Because market value of debt I
might be able to get away with, right?
You can take the present, but there's no
market value of equity. Bigger number.
See, can I use book equity? Off the
table. Not even a choice. God only knows
what goes into book equity for a private
company. Right? So, you have two
choices. One is you can call the owner
and say, "Do you have a target market
debt to equity ratio?" You can try this.
It's never worked for me cuz the
reaction is a target. What? It's a
restaurant. It's some French chef. You
know what does he, you know, he doesn't
think it as a target debt to equity. I
can give you the recipe for my, you
know, my French duck. I don't know what
a target debt to equity is. Never
worked. The second is to use the
industry average and say there's a
reason publicly traded restaurants have
a debt to equity and stay with the debt
to equity.
There's actually a third choice which is
use your own estimated value of equity
to get to a debt to equity
ratio. It's tricky though, right? What's
the problem with doing that? There's
circularity. To get the estimated value
of equity, I need a debt to equity.
Luckily, in Excel spreadsheet, you check
the iteration box. It actually works for
private companies. If if you if you want
to, you can make your estimated value of
equity be the debt to equity. So
basically there's a there's circularity
but the circularity is fixed by the the
iterations going
around. I'm going to stay with the
industrial average here. The industrial
average debt to equity ratio is
14.33%. I assume my company is going to
be close to the average because it's a
restaurant. Restaurants have to have a
certain amount of debt. It's usually
leases. I get a le of 2.56 and a cost of
equity of 1450%.
reflecting the fact that the buyer is
not
diversified. Any questions about the
process? So essentially I'm doing
everything I do for a public company but
this added step is I bring in that
correlation to adjust my beta for the
fact that the buyer is not diversified.
Yeah. The correlation adjustment like an
example of not using that is like if the
buyer is a public company or something
in fact that's going to be the
difference. If buyer is a public
company what should I use? just use the
market beta. What if the buyer is a
venture
capitalist? They're not as undiversified
as somebody who puts all their wealth.
They're not as diversified as a public
investor because venture capitalists
often tend to be sector focused. Your
correlation might be.7 with the market,
their portfolio. What if you're a
private equity investor? It depends on
who you are. If you're KKR or
Blackstone, you're publicly traded
anyway, right?
So you can see that there's a continuum.
I've given you the two limiting cases.
Market beta for somebody who's
completely diversified. Total beta for
somebody who's completely
undiversified. Everybody else is going
to fall somewhere in that continuum
based on the correlation of their
portfolios with the
market. Once you get the cost of equity,
the cost of capital follows. Here again,
the easy ways of looking it up go away,
right? You can't find a bond rating for
a restaurant. You can look for Moody's
or S&P rating. You're not going to find
the French restaurant there. But
luckily, we've opened up the door. And
the reason I built up to estimating cost
of equity and cost of debt the way I did
was I wanted to be able to deal with
companies like this. So, when you don't
have a rating for a public company, what
do you do? You look at the interest
coverage ratio. You can get that for a
private business. It's EBIT divide by
interest expense. I used the interest
coverage ratio to come up with the
default
spread double B+. I took that default
spread added to my risk-free rate. And
here if you want to at the margin add
tweaks for instance you can argue a
private business has to borrow from a
bank. The banks might charge an extra 50
basis points. Why? Because they can and
you have no choice. You can add it in
but effectively you've laid the
foundation for a cost of debt. The one
thing about private businesses though is
how a private business is structured can
affect its tax rate. A private business
can be structured as a subchapter S
corporation which case income just flows
through to the owners. You're not taxed
at the business level. You're taxed as
an individual. You be taxed as a regular
corporation. So you have to know how the
investment banker plans to structure it.
Here assume that he's going to stay.
This is going to become just a business
he owns and it's going to go through
into this 1040 is is a traditional
income tax return. His tax rate becomes
his tax rate as an individual. So that
40% tax rate might reflect that
individual's tax rate. And here you can
see a problem, right? If you have very
high tax rates as an individual, that
can come into play in both the amount of
debt you take and your cost of debt.
Ultimately, the cost of capital using my
assumption that this business will end
up at close to the industry average is
about
13.25%. I'm changing nothing about the
core principles about how I estimate
cost of equity and capital. I'm just
making this what I think is a pragmatic
adjustment to my cost of equity for the
fact that they I mean I know there are
books on how to build a costic app from
scratch for a private business and most
of them break every rule. It's almost
like they act like private businesses
operate in a universe very different
from publicly traded companies. But you
recognize that everybody has a choice,
right? You could run a private business
or put your money in a mutual fund. I'm
allowing for that choice and saying hey
given those
choices that's why my risk-f free rate
and equity risk premium follow the same
rules for as for a public company when
equity risks rise so so should the cost
of capital for every private
business so that's the first step
getting the discount rate you saw the
additional tweaks required on my web
page I actually have the bottom up betas
by sector which some of you might have
used that are built into my spreadsheet
but I also have bottom up total betas by
sector
So, if you want to see the other end of
what the cost of equity looks like, you
can check that out. It looks just like
my model. Sometimes I have people who
get into that page by mistake, think
they're looking up the beta for a
company, and then I get emails saying,
"How come the beta for chemicals is
4.25?" And I said, "Are you sure you're
looking at a beta and it's right in
front of me? It's a beta page." I said,
"Can you look at the beta and say, does
it say total beta?" And said, "Yeah, I
saw that. I don't even know what the
total is there for. It's there for a
reason. And it's for private business
transactions where the buyer is not
diversified. That's why it's so high.
That's why the average beta for the
market is 3.6. This is not something
you'd see with a market beta, but you
can see that with a total beta. So my
sec second stop is I've got to clean up
the financial statements. Some of the
cleaning up is going to be what I'd have
done with a public company like what in
a public this was before 2019. If you're
a public company, lease commitments,
what did I do? I converted the lease
commitments to debt. I cleaned up for
those lease commitments. I did the same
thing here. If the private business is
R&D, I would do exactly what I did with
public companies. Capitalize the R&D.
Luckily, there wasn't much R&D at the
restaurant, so I could ignore it. But I
did
introduce a salary for a
chef. Might seem like, you know, that
I'm hiring a chef for 150,000. I don't
know what it I I you probably have to go
check out the markets for chefs. I'm
probably underpaid here. I don't know.
But I have to bring in a chef reflecting
the fact that I want this restaurant to
be filled up. The chef not only needs to
know how to cook probably has to come
with the profile that people recognize
that they will come. Remember this is
not just how good the food is, but who's
cooking the food, right? It's this. So
maybe I want to go on the Food Network
and watch who, you know, the big names,
who's recognized, hire one of those
guys and pay them an
amount and that's got to be part of my
expenses. So I make those adjustments.
It changes my operating income, my
taxable income, my net income because
but this is I think a more realistic
sense of what I'm getting as a
company. My third step is going to be a
tough one.
This restaurant is doing well. It's
getting filled up, but it's got a chef
that people know the name. They come to
the restaurant for the chef,
right? If I buy the restaurant and that
person leaves, the question is, how many
of my clients will leave? You can see
why this question is going to be
difficult to answer, right? You got to
hang out around the restaurant, say,
"Hey, right now this guy cooks. Would
you come back to the restaurant if
somebody else cooked?" I'm not sure
you'll get an answer to that question,
but let's assume in this case you come
up with an estimate. 20% of my operating
income is going to go away if this guy's
not there. If it's a 100%, you know what
the end result is, right? Don't buy the
restaurant. It's worth nothing to you.
You'll get a shell, the name, but
nothing else. You know how many bad
transactions would stop if you just
stopped and asked the question of people
buying a business and the key person
leaves and takes the entire business
with them, right?
So you take off 20% of the operating
income. What does it do? It reduces the
income. It reduces the value. And if
you're the chef, this hurts you as well,
right? Because I'm willing to pay you
less. I'll tell you a kind of related
story to bring home how this can be this
can be a factor. I have four kids.
They're no longer kids. My youngest is
26. My oldest is
35. But when they were kids, three of
the four needed braces. One of them
escaped that that
ordeal. And I never because I never got
braces. I didn't realize how lucrative
this business was. The repeat business.
I thought you put braces on then you
came back 10 years later and you took
the braces off. It doesn't work that
way. It turns out every month you got to
go back and they readjust the braces. I
think they do it just to make you to
come back. So my kids had this dentist,
his name was Howie. So every month I
would be the person designated to take
the three kids in to get their braces
adjusted and how we ran this factory of
brace adjusting going on. We walked in
every chair was filled with kids braces
being adjusted and how we love to talk
about markets. So every time you come
and say can I talk to you I have some
investments I need to make you know and
I listen my kids have their mouth open
with somebody you know you you can't say
look I can't talk now because that might
be time for torture then for your kids
and how is a nice guy I like them so I
bring my kids in know and he says look
I'm thinking of retiring I said you're
42 years old how he says I've made a lot
of money I said I know I check my credit
card every month right And he said,
"Look, I'm planning to sell my business
and you know how." So he said, "How
would I?" So I led him through the
process. And then I hit him with a key
person question. I said, "Be ready for a
pretty significant discount." Especially
because these are people bring their
kids in. And if you sold your business,
some guys went in and said, and you
walked in and said, "Who are you?" And
said, "I'm your new dentist." You said,
"No, you're not. I'm going to walk out
of the door."
And he was, you know, so I led him
through and he recognized there was
going to be a big discount, maybe 40%,
50%. And he said, "What can I
do to keep that disc to make that
discount smaller?" Can you give him some
advice? What should how do to make the
discount smaller?
Resell it. So which is can he have his
cake? Can he sell it
and when he hangs around after he sells
it for a couple of years, right? Get
yourself a nice massage chair. You don't
even have to do dentistry. Just hang out
there as people come in with their
kids. You make small talk. How is really
good at small talk. Walk them over to
the chair. Let the new dentist in and
say, "This is the new dentist. I'll be
around in case you have a problem." Lot
of private company transactions. There's
usually an overlap period between the
old doctor, the old dentist, the old
plumber, the old electrician, and the
new buyer. Yeah. So the first thing is
you try to create that overlap so you
don't have that G person issue. And if
you're buying this business, not only do
you want that, you also want to make
sure that when Howie leaves, he doesn't
start a dental practice next door and
suck up all your patients, right? So you
got to get these. So already you can see
selling is not just getting the best
possible price. It's massaging the rest
of the process so you can minimize that
drainage and value.
And this is a more general issue of key
persons. And this is something I wrote
about a couple of years ago because this
is not just in private business anymore,
right? Is Jensen Wong a key part of
Nvidia? Yeah, I think
so. And remember, human beings, it's not
just they leave. Other things can
happen. It can affect your
value. And the key person doesn't just
have be a CEO, right? It could be a key
salesperson. Remember, in many
businesses, there are some people really
good at selling. They can account for
half the sales. You buy the business,
the salesperson leaves, that's half your
business. It can be sometimes a key
spokesperson, usually a celebrity you've
hired as
your the person who's that person has a
scandal in their lives. Hey, they can
drag your company down because people
are
so when Tiger Wood, you know, drove his
car into the tree, Nike lost 4 billion
in market cap. You said, "What did they
have in that tree? Why did they lose
it?" That's what happens when you tie
your name to a celebrity. It could be a
key design
person, John
IV. Big part of Apple's success, right?
When you look at your iPhone now, that's
the John Iv effect playing
on you be a key production person,
somebody who knows how to run a factory
more efficiently who's really, you
know, and this is the least likely
scenario could be a key finance person.
Let's face it, finance is the one area
where key is really tough to think of.
What can you do? Lower the cost of debt?
No. But maybe if you're a private
business, you have access to venture
capitalist. So if you leave in a sense
your capital flow might become
more. How do you value key person?
Basically value the company twice. I
mean I think of this as just having a
lever you need DCF. This is with the key
person. This is without the difference
is the value of that key
person. In fact you want to try it on
really interesting company. Take Tesla
and Elon Musk right with without with
without. It used to be a slam dunk 10
years ago with Elon Musk worth a lot
without worth very little. Now it's
become much more I don't know whether
which whether the switch is on or off,
right? Because you don't know is it a
good thing or a bad thing. And there
might be a time where turning off the
switch might give you a higher value,
right? And just because you're adding a
private business doesn't mean you ignore
all the stuff we talked about with
public companies. What do you have to do
to grow? You got to reinvest. How much
do you have to reinvest? It depends on
your returns on return capital. This is
nothing to do with private or public.
It's just one of the laws of business.
So in this case, I did assume a growth
rate close to inflation rate. Why?
Because I don't want to keep building
new
restaurants. So you're saying, why is
there reinvestment then? Because that
growth is close to inflation rate. Then
I have to replace my my my ovens, top
end ovens with new ovens 10 years from
now. They'll cost me more. There's
inflation in those as well. That
reinvestment is small, but it's still
there because I need to reinvest to keep
my kitchen in working order, to keep my
restaurant looking
good at
10%. I'm pretty much ready to do my
valuation. I start with the adjusted
EIT. Why adjusted? Because I lowered the
EIT by 20% because a chef is leaving. I
used a 40% tax rate reflecting your tax
rate as an investment banker coming into
play. I computed the cost of capital
based on the fact that you were not
diversified as a buyer and the
reinvestment rate of 10%. The value that
I got for the restaurant was $1.449 449
million expected cash flow next year
essentially it's just a present it's so
nothing here is different from what I
done with the public company
othered growth rate
then why
I'm sorry what did I do you put the
expected growth rate as 2% right rather
than the risk free rate are you required
to use the risk free rate is a cap right
so when you grow the risk free rate what
am I implicitly having to do I have to
have real growth. What does it mean in a
restaurant to have real growth? I can't
fit more chairs in the same space,
right? I can't rush you out. It's a
French restaurant. I say it's been 45
minutes. You know, you got to leave
right now. You guys are talking too
much. Basically, there are only certain
amount of seedings I can do. So, to have
a real growth rate, I have to either
expand the
restaurant or add another restaurant.
have it as I can have a different
business model but then I will have to
bring in a reinvestment that reflects
it. So don't let the growth rate be
equal to the risk free rate for every
business because especially in a private
business you're kind of stuck with
capacity constraints. You might say all
I can do is grow at the inflation
rate. So my value for the equity was
only 521,000.
If you look at it as a multiple of
earnings, it's like two and a half times
net income, three times net income,
which looks low, right? P ratio of
three. But with private business is that
high cost of equity and cost of capital.
And I haven't even applied a liquidity
discount yet, right? This is my value on
an intrinsic value
basis. Any questions about the
mechanics? Yes. You apply a terminal
value or Yeah, I did apply this is
basically the terminal value, right?
Remember the terminal value doesn't have
to be in year 10. If you're already a
mature company, you can just do the
terminal value today. So this is the
stable growth model in perpetuity. Now I
thought you question you ask is can I
use a finite life because in private
business let's say you have this lease
for the next 25 years. You might say
look I'm going to do 25 years of cash
flows and end because I have no idea
whether I can even renew the lease.
Right? It's perfectly okay. Private
businesses you could say look I'm not
going to assume a perpetuity. I'm just
going to use 25
years. Now, let's go think about u
liquidity. I've already laid the
foundations for thinking about ili
liquidity. There is an illquidity issue
with private businesses. There should be
a discount on that
521,000. But it should be different
depending on the company I'm valuing,
healthy or unhealthy, money-making,
money losing. It should depend on when
I'm doing the valuation. Is it 200 and
21 or 2025 because the market's affected
and it should depend on the buyer.
Notice how much a private company
valuation is a function of knowing who
the buyer is, understanding it. And
that's good, right? Because we talked
about how much a valuation has become
mechanized and how Chachi PT can do it.
If you're a good private company
appraiser, it's going to be far more
difficult for an AI engine to do what
you do because you might not even
because you can ask a buyer, do you have
other investments on the side, but most
of the time they're going to refuse to.
But you might look at his house and
where he lives and his zip code and the
car he drives and kind of form judgments
about what else is in his portfolio or
her portfolio, which chat GPT will not
be able to do. I think so. It is nuanced
because it's very much a function of
bar. So let's talk about u liquidity.
I'll I'll give you the standard way of
dealing with the liquidity is to apply
this hefty discount 20
25%. Where does it come from? It
basically comes from two sets of
incredibly flawed studies and explain
why they're flawed of what are called
restricted
stocks. and what happens in companies
before an IPO, pre-IPO
transactions. Remember to observe the
cost of illiquidity. I've got to be able
to observe what people would have paid
if something is liquid. And then and
most of the time you look at private
company transactions, what you observe
is the actual price. You don't observe
what they would have paid where didn't
care about liquidity. Saying how do
these two samples get rid of it? First,
let me explain what restricted stock is.
Restricted stock is stock issued by
publicly traded companies with
restrictions on trading on that stock.
You can't trade it for the next year or
the next two years. Now, now I know
companies issue restricted stock to
employees, but they you don't observe a
price. So, these have to be restricted
stock issued to the general market.
Already you can see it's rare. You know,
relatively few companies do it and we'll
see why. But when you are an investor in
a company and it issues restricted so
it's a publicly traded company and they
say look you can buy these shares but
you can't trade them for the next two
years even though there's a market price
out there you will not pay that market
price why because I'm restricting you
from trading I can observe then what you
pay and I'm getting a measure of the
discount so that's what makes restricted
stock so attractive to liquidity
researchers in an
IPO there is that IPO price so if I can
observe transactions in the months
leading up to the
IPO. Given that you're selling before an
IPO, you're in a sense getting rid of
that illquidity until the IPO. You can
observe how much lower than the IPO
price that you get and say there's my
discount by comparing what's what's paid
to the
IPO. I I said they were deeply flawed.
We'll see why that is. Let's start with
the restricted stock studies. For a long
time, every restricted stock study,
here's what it did. It'll take all the
companies that issued restricted stock.
It look at the price at which the
restricted stock is issued compared to
the public market price and take that
difference and that would be the
discount. And for much of the lifetime
of restricted stock studies they would
take the median discount across all
these restricted stock companies and
then come up with numbers like 25 30
35%. And for two decades that became the
basis that private company appraisers
used when they went in front of court or
the IRS saying we value the company we
knocked off 30%. Look at the restricted
stock
status until Bill Silbo used to teach
the foundations of finance class here.
So he used to be the lead into my class
about few decades ago decided to do a
study and he still laughs about it
because like a summer throwaway research
project where he took the restricted
stock companies and rather than just
report the median he looked at the
discount in each restricted stock
transaction and he said why are the
discounts different? A very statistical
and logical question to answer and he
noticed that the discount was larger at
companies with small revenues than big
revenues.
He found that the discount was larger at
money making was larger at money losing
companies than money-making companies.
So he built up a regression of let's see
what the discount is. He actually did
one minus the discount and he basically
related to the revenues of the company
whether it was money making or money
losing. He even threw in whether the
people buying the restricted stock had
any special relationship with the
company because they might accept a
smaller discount if they were suppliers.
and he built up a regression
equation. But collectively restricted
stock studies find big discounts and
discounts vary across companies based on
size. I could take that silver study in
fact I did and I kind of took it the
extra step. I said there let's start
with a median discount of 25%. Said
that's your median discount. The silver
study says it's smaller for companies
with more in revenues and less for
companies and smaller revenues. by how
much? I just took the the coefficient on
revenues and converted it into an effect
on discount. So you tell me how much
your revenues are based on the silver
study. I will adjust your base discount
down if you're a company with a billion
dollars in revenues as opposed to 100
million. I'm probably taking a
coefficient of regression that's noisy
and doing crazy things with it, but I
really have no choice here. I also did
money making versus money losing. Say,
how would I lose this? Let's say you're
a private company appraiser. I walk into
the private business. What's the first
question you're going to ask me? Are you
making money or losing money? So, let's
have money losing. How much revenues do
I have? Let's say I have a 100 million
in revenues. 100 million revenues, money
losing company. My discount is going to
be
28%. Next guy walks in, I'm a
money-making company with a billion
dollars in revenues. Your discount is
going to be closer to 15%.
I'm starting to adjust the discount for
who you are as a company based on your
revenues and money making or money
losing but I'm building off a base
discount that still look comes from
looking across all restricted
stock the IPO discount there's some
studies you look and say I don't believe
these numbers I know they they come from
D it just doesn't make sense and I'll
tell you what these studies and this is
what they're looking at they're looking
at companies that go public they take
the IPO price. They look at the
transactions that occur between VCs and
the VC and the founder in the months
leading up and they document how much of
a discount and the discounts are just
monstrously
large. So if you look at the discount on
IPOs, I don't even know whe this is the
right graph in here. That's actually the
wrong graph. The discounts on the IPOs
are like 35% 40% 50%. Let me ask you a
question. You are a venture capitalist
in a company that's planning to go
public in 4 months. Your expected
offering price is 100. Would you sell
your steak to me at
$60? I mean, all you have to do is wait
four months, right? There's something
clearly wrong. Nobody discounts value
that much for four months of liquidity.
There's a statistical problem with each
of these studies and all a private
company appraisal is built on these two
stud two groups of
studies. I want you to identify what
that statistical problem is first with
the restricted stock
studies. Where is the because clearly
these numbers look too high to be
believable. What do you think the
statistical problem is with the
restricted
stocks?
Remember what you do when you issue
restricted stock? You take a 35% or a
30%
discount on the current stock price to
issue those shares, right? Who does
that? Desperate
companies. So what do you have? You have
a sample of really desperate companies
teetering on the
edge issuing restricted talk. You're
saying, "So what?" Some of that discount
you see with that restricted stock is
really a sampling bias problem which is
if you're I mean you could issue any
kind of equity you're probably you try
to raise any kind of capital you're
weight watchers right
now I'm not exact people are not lining
up to buy your
equity so the first restricted stock
studies the problem is so in fact the
the IRS used to take these things as a
given and accept them because remember
the biggest penalty paid here is by
because many of these valuations were
for tax purposes and if you put a 35%
discount on your
value that's a big chunk of taxes that
the IRS doesn't collect. So for the
longest time IRS was cheap about hiring
expert witnesses. So basically the game
became the expert witness for the
taxpayer would come up with the high end
of the restricted stock discount 40%.
the expert for the IRS would come in
with the low end of the restricted stock
which is 30%. What do courts do? They
split the difference at 35%. It's a
stupid game that the IRS were going to
lose until finally the IRS hired
somebody who knew basic statistics who
took that restricted stock discount and
deconstructed into how much of the
discount is for liquidity and how much
comes from the sampling bias. the fact
that these are desperate and it worked
out that about 10 to 12% of the discount
came from the fact that they were for
liquidity. The rest came from the
sampling
bias. With the IPOs, you have a
different sampling problem. How how are
you doing the IPO studies? You're
looking at companies that go public and
then working backwards and looking at
transactions leading to the IPO, right?
What are you missing when you do that?
Do all companies that plan to go public
actually go
public? In other words, as you're
looking at the IPOs that went public,
but in fact, if you're doing this right,
you should start 6 months ahead of every
company planning to go public. And those
companies that don't go public, the guys
who sold early, actually are going to
emerge as winners, right? Because there
was no offering. You're overstating the
discard.
I wouldn't trust the the results from
either study further than I can throw it
because when you have sampling bias it
can be the studies themselves can look
solid but the sampling bias kills
them which my the response from private
company appraisers is what choice do we
have where else can we observe the
liquidity discount my answer is you can
observe it all around you every publicly
traded stock has an equity discount we
call it the bid ask spread there's no
sampling bias I can give you know 48,000
stocks and their liquidity discounts and
if I take the the bid ask spread as a
percentage of the price I'm getting an
liquidity discount for every publicly
traded
company sample size is huge there's no
sampling bias it's incredibly
noisy but about 10 15 years ago I'll
tell you why it's been so long in a
minute I ran a regression of that spread
as opposed to the price against how much
the company has as annual revenues
arguing that you know so think of this
as a silver regression across all public
companies whether it makes money or not
and I was deliberately picking variables
that I could also get for a private
business revenues I can observe earnings
I threw in cash as a person of firm
value again you know you can get that
for a private business and then I threw
in trading volume say you can't that get
that for I do I can in fact it's zero
for a private company so this is a
regression where essentially I have the
spreads across companies. If I take this
regression and plug in the numbers for
the restaurant, restaurants revenues,
the fact that it's a money-making
restaurant, how much cash the restaurant
has on its balance sheet, and throw in
zero as the trading volume. I can get a
predicted bid ass spread of the
restaurant. What does it even mean? It's
a synthetic bid as spread. I've made it
up, but it's essentially my estimate of
the liquidity discount for the
restaurant. But I now have a tool that I
can use for any private company that
comes in. The only problem is that
regression of the spread is a mess to
run because capital IQ doesn't actually
carry. If capital IQ carried the
average, I don't know why they don't do
it. The bid price and the ask price and
I could create the spread. I could run
this every year just like I do
everything else. Update the numbers. I
have to actually combine two different
data sets. There is another data set of
bid aspects but combining data sets
which I set up differently when you have
40 thousands of companies it's an
incredible mess this took me like you
know I thought it was going to be a one
day affair it ended up being like two
weeks unless I'm not coming back to this
for a while I haven't come back to it
ever maybe one of these days be worth
coming back to but I think if your job
my job is not private company place this
is not even my top 50 list of things to
do but if you're in the private company
why aren't doing this yourself. Nothing
I've done here is rocket science. Maybe
hire an intern, pay for the data, do it
once every year, and you'll have a
competitive advantage. You'll have a way
of estimating a liquidity discount
that so private to private, you can see
all of this mess play out. Undiversified
buyers, key person discounts,
illiquidity, private to public, your
problems all magically go away, right?
because it's a public company. It's not
the company that has been diversified.
It's investors. So, you should expect to
see cost of equity and capital that look
very similar to what we've been using
for classes up till now. The tax rates
are now going to be corporate tax rates.
Individual tax rates no longer enter the
mix. And there is no liquidity discount
because your investors, if they want to
sell out, just sell the shares in your
company. So if I took my restaurant and
revalued it using public company data,
my cost to capital being
13.25%. Will be 8.76% market base. So it
look like a traditional company's cost
to capital. That's going to have a big
effect on my value. You take out the
effective liquidity, the value of equity
that I get will
be,484 million. It's like magic. Same
business, different buyer doesn't care
about liquidity. instead pay for getting
454,000 for my equity. I'm getting 1.48
million. So, let's say you are the chef,
right? What do you think you're going to
get for your business? 454,000
1.48.
No, let's say that I am the potential
buyer and I'm a public company. What are
you going to start your your ask
at? 1.48. You know what? I'm going to
start my bid
at
454,000. And then we're going to meet
somewhere between those two numbers,
right? Where do you think we're going to
end up? Closer to the 1.484 million or
close to the
453,000? If I'm the only game in town,
you know what? I'm going to extract the
maximum out of this transaction. This is
why rollups work because I can offer you
a $50,000 premium. I act like I'm being
magnanimous saying you're going to get
$450,000 the next best buyer. I'm
offering you
$525,000. I'm walking away with a big
chunk, but what choice do I have? So, if
you're the seller, you're at a
disadvantage unless you do
what? You get another public buyer
involved.
Because now the game changes, right?
Because now they're bidding against the
other public buyer. You go back and
forth. And if you're working this game,
right, you're going to push the number
up towards 1.484 million. The key to
selling a a private business is finding
the right buyer and getting that right
buyer to start to bid against an
imaginary other buyer who has the same
character. Make it it sometimes can be
imaginary. You can create, oh, I've been
approached by another public company.
You make up a name. Um, they will try to
check, but they can't check. It's
confidential. But you're getting the
game going, trying to get the number.
But if your best potential bidder is a
venture capitalist, you're not quite at
either extreme, right? You can't get the
1.484 million, then you're going to have
to settle for less. And there the effect
will depend on what kind of total beta
you're going to get with a correlation
of 0.8 8 or 80% instead of the 50% that
we use. You can see that this now
becomes this very dynamic exercise of
depending on who's on the other side of
the table what you end up. But if you're
a priv if you're a private owner, you
want to have both numbers, right? You
got to have the 450 4,000 in one pocket
and the 1.484 million in the other
pocket. Remember which pocket of which
number, otherwise it can get really bad.
and essentially start your bidding at
the 1.484 million. That's your maximum
and the 4854 will be your essentially
your you basically won't need take the
transaction if it drops below that. That
then becomes effectively the the limits
that you use to try to get the best
price for yourself. So private to public
becomes very much like a traditional
valuation. Talk a little bit about
private to
IPO first. In an IPO, the private
company is now going to become a
publicly traded company. Right? This
issue of diversification becomes
irrelevant because investors who buy
your shares have that choice. If they
choose not to be diversified, that's
their problem.
You But there are other things that also
change. First is your position as the
person running the company becomes
shakier the minute you go public because
now you're a public company. You're
answerable to shareholders. And to the
extent that you've not fixed the game,
there is at least a chance now that
control could change and you have to be
responsive and your information
disclosure requirements will now become
that of a public company and it can be
much more ownorous than being a private
business. Talk about the valuation
aspect of an IPO. Right? To value an
IPO, you're valuing it like a public
company. You got cash flows, you got a
cost of capital, everything looks very
similar. But I want to focus in on the
things that are different. So I'm going
to take you back to October 5th of 2013.
That was the day that Twitter filed its
prospectus saying it was going to go
public. When company when I value
companies that are planning to go
public, I try to value them right after
the prospectus is filed rather than wait
a few weeks. You know
why? Because no offering price has been
set yet. It's said, remember we talk
about bias. The minute a price gets
mentioned, whether you like it or not,
it's going to weasel its way into your
valuation. So you have a clean slate.
You're looking at the number saying,
"How much should I value the company?"
This was my October 5th, 2013 valuation
of Twitter. Essentially, I, you know,
valued as an online with a story of a
company that was going to be an online
advertising company, a successful
online, but not
um not your primary online advertising
vehicle, right? a Facebook or a Google
can end up being a but Twitter I felt
would be something that companies would
use as a secondary advertising vehicle.
So I projected out revenues based on
that the original valuations there you
can read my story but the bottom line is
until I got to the value of equity and
the value per share everything looks
pretty much the same. The only
difference is when you when I add you
know how once you value the operating
assets you add cash. I added the cash
and then I added IPO
proceeds. What is that? What happens on
the offering day Michael? Well a primary
and a secondary typically primary you
issue shares. The cash from the shares
comes to the
company. Okay. We'll talk about what the
company can do with the cash here. What
am I assuming the company does with the
cash?
It keeps it right. You're saying what
are the choices? We'll talk about the
other ways in which the offering
proceeds could have played out here. It
kept it. So the minute after you do the
offering, your value of the company will
jump by roughly the amount of that cash
you're going to bring in. Your cash
balance increases. The day Alibaba went
public, its value increased by 20
billion because that's what the offering
proceeds were. A big increase in cash.
So that's the first thing. So the rest
of the valuation looks very much the
same, right? Cost of equity, cost of
capital. So when you value an IPO, the
real question becomes know dealing with
those special issues. I want to focus on
first dealing with the proceeds that
come from the offering and then talking
a little bit about the debris that these
companies bring in to the going public
process because remember they've raised
capital six, seven, eight times before
they went public and they all leave
imprints on the company. So let's look
at the the issues that are specific to
IPOs. One is to value an IPO, you need
to know what the company plans to do
with the proceeds from the IPO and it'll
be in the prospective so it's not going
to be a mystery. You can look it up.
Second, to the extent that this company
has raised money from other claimants
over time, venture capitalists for
instance, each venture capital round
comes with its own class of security and
often special claims, options, warrants
that you've given those venture
capitalists to be players in the company
and all of that has to be cleaned
up. And if you look at the IPO itself
and pricing the IPO, you have a set of
institutional issues. How are most IPOs
structured?
You're a private company. You want to go
public. What do you do with
uh you'll set a lower price so that no
first you don't even set a price because
after all you're a
company you before you do the road show
you first pick an investment bank right
the investment bank sets up a syndicate.
The syndicate does a road show. the
roach after the pricing happens of you
know as you get further down the process
and the investment maker makes you a
promise that sounds too good to be true
which is in most IPOs they guarantee you
the offering price this is amazing right
it's like having a realtor guarantee a
price but not mention what the price
is so for the moment it's an empty
promise we'll set a price and we
guarantee it we'll see how that plays
out but the clear thing is that pricing
ing the
IPO. Why their objective of a successful
IPO is clear market has to clear this is
a pricing
game not a valuation game. What I've
done is a DCF. It's probably relevant in
how you price this company. So let's
talk a little bit about the proceeds.
There are three users you can put
proceeds to. First is you can raise the
money and keep it in the company. That
just pushes up the cash. That's what I
did for Twitter. You know what Spotify
did when it made when it made its
initial public offering? It let owners
cash out. People who were found, you
know, venture capitalists like Sony had
a stake in Spotify cashed out. So the
second thing that can happen is the cash
is used so leave the firm. That's
actually the easiest of all because it
just transitions through the firm.
Nothing to deal
with. The third is you can use the
proceeds to pay down debt. Why would you
have debt? Because you were desperate.
you went out and raised that strange
oxymoronic component called venture
capital debt or VC debt which shouldn't
even exist but venture capitals often
use it as you know kind you saying I
don't want that debt so that's the first
thing you check for so taken out of the
firm you can ignore it so owners cash
out if it left in the firm you can add
if it used to pay down debt how is it
going to show up in your valuation if I
told you Twitter was going to use the
billion to pay down debt and your cost
of capital debt would change because
your debt rate should be different shows
up in different places. As for the
proceeds of for
Twitter, there was a it's tough to
estimate because you have to know the
dollar proceeds you're going to raise,
but that was actually in the news
stories right from the beginning that
they were planning to raise about a
billion from the offering. And in the
Twitter prospectus filing, they were
clear about what they were going to do
with the billion. They were going to
leave it in the company because they had
investment needs they thought they would
have in the
future. So none of this has to be
assumed. It has to be part of Yes.
When when you say the owners cash out,
why would they do why would they cash
out? I mean, usually don't they get a
big bump, right? But they get at the
bumped up price, right? So basically, so
they're cashing out at the offer price.
So let's assume that IPOs companies go
public at the peak of their fad status.
If you're owner, you're saying, "I'm
cashing out now, guys, because
everything from now is going to be
downhill because people are going to
discover the truth about you." So a
subset of owners say I'm I you know this
company is not worth as much as what the
public market does. Some of it just
might be that they don't want to own
shares in a public company and have
cross holdings. So there are lots of
reasons people might cash out but many
of them would stay in the company. In
fact in most on that offering day in
most companies many of the VCs are not
allowed to cash out.
They're actually required to continue
hold for 6 months or a year after the
offering before they're unlocked and
they can actually go trade. But some
some owners will cash
out. So when I ask how would the
valuation have been different if half
the proceeds had been withdrawn by
owners would have changed my valuation?
Yeah, sure. The cash that addon of a
billion I'd have added only half a
billion. Everything else in the process
would have stayed exactly the same.
Right. Yes, Michael. Could there be some
like deep person risk too? Like I'm just
like thinking about say if like Elon
took SpaceX, you know, public but then
sold, you know, 80% of his shares, you
know, people would maybe question to ask
is how much of these cash flows come
from having the founder around? But Elon
is not at SpaceX anyway, right? So it
wouldn't be as much of an issue, but
it's somebody who is involved in the
cash flows making a big role. When you
value the IPO, you got to factor in
whether the founder stays on. And if
that founder is that critical, usually
as part of the IPO, they will bind
themselves to stay with the company
because it's like that check. It's like
Howie saying, "I'll stay on for two
years after I want to retire because I
want to get the higher value." Right?
Now, as I said, often by the time a
company goes public, it's had these
round after round of venture capital
getting there, which means that you have
multiple classes of securities that have
built up. In the case of Twitter, at the
the the day they filed their prospectus,
there were seven classes of convertible
preferred
stock. You know what that tells me,
right? There've been at least seven
rounds of venture capital. So, you can
almost count the number of rounds by
looking at the number of classes.
Facebook at 12
classes. Luckily, in most IPOs, those
get converted into shares. You don't
have to worry about them as as things
that stay on. But they also had
restricted stock units they'd been
giving to their employees that was going
to carry over into the new company. I'm
going to count those as shares. They had
40 44.16 million employee options that
were continued into the company and the
strike price was set. So I had to bring
them in as well. So you do this with
every company but with a young company
there are multiple layers of this you
got to go through. So next time you see
a prospectus read through the number of
restricted stock units. It's public.
It's disclosed and you got to bring them
into your share count and your value per
share. So this in this case as part of
the prospective they said the
convertible preferred to be converted
into share count. They gave me the share
count. That share count is going to
become a key component in what you
attach as the value per
share. And finally, let's talk about the
investment banking guarantee. It sounds
great, right? They guaranteed an
offering price. The only problem is they
don't tell you what the price is till 24
or 48 hours before the offering. It used
to be two weeks before the offering
about late 1980s when British Petroleum
at that time where the British
government owned a big part of British
Petroleum. They were doing an IPO where
they were going to make it privatized
and the investment banker set the price
two weeks before the IPO and the price
the market collapsed in those two weeks.
The October 19th, 1987 collapse
happened. In one of the most pathetic
shows of lack of backbone, the banks
went to the British government and beg
to be let out of the guarantee saying we
didn't mean for this guarantee for a
thing this that's like insuring your
house and then you have a fire. It burns
a whole house down. The insurance
company says you know what we didn't
expect the fire to be this big. If it
had been just in the kitchen would have
come the whole house seems to have
burned down. Why do you think I have
fire insurance? It's because my house
can burn down. And to give the British
government credit, they said, "No, you
guaranteed it. You stick with the
guarantee." But the thing investment
bank has learned is two weeks is too
long. Let's make it two days left at,
you know, let's do 2 minutes before.
Let's see what the order flow is and
then we'll set the offering price. But
they're trying to minimize their risk.
But basically, if you look at the
process, the pricing
process. So if if you ask me why have
investment bankers set the offering
price they did for whatever the company
is my reaction is they're not valuing
the company they're pricing the company
based on what everything we talked about
by looking at number of users number of
subscribers and that's why when I looked
at Twitter I said look I can do an
intrinsic valuation of the company it's
not that I can't do it but if you're
looking at the IPO pricing it has
nothing to do with that intrinsic value
it's got everything to do with
pricing and Twitter the pricing was
based on number of users cuz what else
did you
have that 20 240 million users times
$100 per user gave me a pretty good
sense of what the pricing would look
like and this might have been
coincidence but the offering price was
driven because your game as a banker is
and I'm not blaming the bank bankers the
IPO process is a pricing process because
your job as a banker is to make sure the
market clears on that open so I'm going
to leave you with a final part and This
is what we're going to this the very
last part of packet two. So next session
will start in packet
three. So the investment bankers
guarantee a price right? So if the price
is higher is higher than that they're
okay. But the price drops below they've
got to cover the difference. So as an
investment banker do you think you have
an incentive to underpric
IPOs? Yeah. In fact every IPO handbook
you go investment bank it's explicit
price. They say value the company. What
they say is price the company and then
reduce that price by 15 to
20%. And if you look at the actual IPO
pricing, this plays out. On average on
the offering day, the day the trading
opens, the price jumps by about 10 to
15%. This looks like an amazing way to
make money, right? Which is to do what?
take every
IPO, try to get in the off the offering
price and then sell on the first day. I
want you to think about why if it's so
easy to make money on IPOs, nobody seems
to make money on it. What is it about
the process that makes it so difficult
to take advantage of that discounting
that investment bankers explicitly do?
And next session we'll start by you know
mopping up that part and then we'll move
on to options. So bring your packet
three after the third quiz because we'll
start in packet three. But I will see
you on Monday and and I will have office
hours on Sunday. So I will send you the
the zoom link so that if you have any
questions about the quiz you can ask
those questions.